[Música]
y
aún no ha empezado nada serio en ucrania
intenten derrotarnos en el campo de
batalla con estas y otras frases el
presidente de rusia vladimir putin
amenazó a occidente a hacer parte de esa
serie de comentarios que se suman a
otros que ya ha hecho en el pasado otro
tipo de amenazas o advertencias como por
ejemplo la que hizo la semana pasada en
donde decía que una guerra nuclear en
europa podría dejarla reducida a cenizas
escuchemos
hoy escuchamos que quieren derrotarnos
en el campo de batalla bueno que decir a
eso que lo intenten ya hemos escuchado
mucho que occidente quiere luchar contra
nosotros hasta el último plan ya no esta
es una tragedia para el pueblo ucraniano
pero parece que todo apunta a eso y un
crain's con neruda dopaje
suquet un guiño a su turno el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de ucrania
dmitro que le va responsabilizó a rusia
de mantener un bloqueo naval que no
permite la salida de toneladas de trigo
y cereales ucranianos que deben ser
exportados al resto del mundo escuchar
los
países rusia está básicamente jugando a
los juegos del hambre con el mundo al
mantener el bloqueo naval de los puertos
ucranianos y al culpar a ucrania con la
otra mano en fate guys the other hand
russia de la dependencia de otros países
en cualquier tipo de recursos como una
debilidad y una invitación a usar esta
dependencia para incrementar la ganancia
de rúsia
a los niños a pesar de todo esto y de
las discusiones útiles que deberían
permitirnos preguntarle a todos nuestros
colegas occidentales cosas muy francas
no hay respuestas sólo hay rusofobia y
rabia en vez de tratar de encontrar un
lugar común que tanto se necesita en
asuntos clave como la economía global y
las finanzas para lo que fue creado el
g20
bueno no es una novedad que el
presidente de rusia vladimir putin
armetta contra occidente y reafirme que
su país no tiene la culpa del conflicto
armado en ucrania repasemos algunos de
los hechos destacados de la semana en
torno al conflicto en el este de europa
a lo largo de los últimos días el
conflicto se ha enfocado en ataques
puntuales en crematorio jarkiv y slavia
nsq otros dos hechos también fueron
destacados a lo largo de esta semana el
primero de ellos la firma de ese
protocolo ya formal por parte de los 30
integrantes de la otan para la
incorporación a esta alianza militar de
países como suecia y finlandia el
segundo hecho también destacado de esta
semana es la conferencia que tuvo lugar
en suiza para la reconstrucción de
ucrania los participantes acordaron
rehabilitar este país a pesar de que el
conflicto no ha terminado
son creíbles entonces estas amenazas del
presidente vladimir putin
a esta altura y con un conflicto que ya
amenaza con extenderse hay espacio
entonces para una mesa de diálogo el
presidente putin ha dicho que si lo hay
que hay una para una mesa de diálogo
pero que esta ventana se irá reduciendo
si el conflicto se prolonga en el tiempo
por eso hoy en el debate de france 24
hacemos un repaso por los hechos más
recientes en torno a la guerra de
ucrania y proyectamos lo que pueda
suceder en los próximos días de acuerdo
al análisis que puedan hacer nuestros
invitados por eso hemos convocado para
este programa a viridiana y yo a ella es
internacionalista especialista en
gobernanza y globalización es también
analista de geopolítica ya se encuentra
en santiago de querétaro en méxico y
desde la ciudad de viña del mar en chile
se conecta fernando wilson él es el
doctor en historia y es docente de la
universidad adolfo ibáñez en chile les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación dejen todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
también en instagram y en facebook en
donde no se encuentran como arroba
france24 guión bajo s arroba sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo la etiqueta para que dejen sus
comentarios es numeral el debate efe
también en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y también aprovecho
para saludar a las personas que nos
están escuchando a través de nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
el debate que ya está disponible en app
el podcast en spotify en dice y en ti un
link
bueno pues damos inicio entonces al
análisis a esta conversación saludo a
viridiana ulloa como lo decía ya se
encuentra en querétaro en mexico
viridiana gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa y punto de partida para
el análisis las recientes amenazas del
presidente putin siempre está dejando
ese manto de dudas sobre las acciones
que puede tomar rusia y a lo largo de
las semanas vemos una amenaza tras otra
que tanto podemos creer que lo que hemos
visto en ucrania no es el inicio de lo
que rusia puede alcanzar a hacer
bueno muchas gracias en efecto la
personalidad de alguien como vladimir
putin es bastante completa tendríamos
que remontarnos un poco si queremos
estudiar un poco pero si recuerdan que
formo parte en algún momento en la que
se ve también fue espía de la calle de
podemos saberlo por lo que realmente
tratar de interpretar sus mensajes
resulta bastante complejo ya que como
sabemos la narrativa no siempre coincide
con el contexto real recordemos
inicialmente cuando comenzaron estos
conflictos 19 de febrero que él mismo
había dicho que no tenía intención de
invadir por área y bueno hoy meses
después seis meses después nos
encontramos con una realidad bastante
diferente
sin embargo es cierto que debemos de
tomar en serio las amenazas de un país
como lo es rusia sabemos que
militarmente hablando
es un gigante al día de hoy y lo hemos
podido constatar en estos bombardeos que
siguen ocurriendo en ucrania y con la
tecnología que sigue desarrollando y
desplegando
pues en estos últimos ataques que ya
hemos podido observar entonces creo que
siempre hay que ir con pies de plomo
cuando hablamos de una personalidad como
lo es la de putin creo que por supuesto
que debemos de tomar con mucha
precaución una amenaza como la que él
dice es decir no es lo único que tenemos
y vamos por más no claro y fernando su
opinión hay en viña del mar también le
doy la bienvenida del programa punto de
partida se puede creer en estas amenazas
debemos alertarnos sobre lo que dice el
presidente vladimir putin y que tanto
está dispuesto a rusia a apostar en este
conflicto lucran ya
antes que nada muchas gracias por la
invitación es una oportunidad
extremadamente interesante de poder
compartir opiniones a ver en términos
prácticos la amenaza de un líder de una
potencia nuclear como es rusia nunca son
menores nunca se deben considerar como
secundarias o irrelevantes e iu pero en
este caso en particular adquieren un
tono de cierta desesperación la semana
pasada ha sido pésima para los intereses
rusos la declaración de la nueva
doctrina de política estratégica de la
otan en la cumbre de madrid
la definición explícita de rusia como
adversario
la incorporación ya formal y avanzada de
finlandia y de suecia las decisiones por
ejemplo alemanas del anuncio de
construir el mayor ejército de europa
continental todo ello sólo contribuye a
reforzar la pesadilla o la visión que
tradicionalmente ha desarrollado
vladimir putin montado sobre los
planteamientos de autores como alexander
su bien etcétera que sostienen la teoría
la fortaleza asediada que rusia sería un
país
envidiado por el mundo que está buscando
ser destruido por intereses nefastos y
en este caso son liderados por el
occidente europeo y los estados unidos
de norteamérica esa combinación de
factores lo hace peligroso sobre todo
porque su capacidad convencional ha
quedado demostrado ineficiente no fue
capaz de derrotar a ucrania y en los
volúmenes de pérdidas constata
prácticamente de vehículos militares de
personal etcétera en alturas son
claramente de las mayores que se han
vivido en cualquier conflicto después
del fin de la guerra fría
fernando continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa y punto el primer
punto en esta agenda después de este
punto de partida son las operaciones que
ha habido a lo largo de esta semana
concentradas ya lo mencionaba yo en
crematorio jarquín y es lo bianco en
kharkiv está un poco más al noreste
lucran ya pero el crematorio y es la
bianca tal parece que son puntos
estratégicos para completar esa
conquista de la región de donets y así
completar la conquista de todo el
donbass
hablamos de estos puntos que tan
importantes para rusia ya conquistar
este par de ciudades que le quedan y eso
que significaría en esa conquista del
donbass
a ver en términos prácticos este es el
objetivo fullback en el objetivo
secundario que rusia se dio a finales de
marzo perdón bendigo a finales de marzo
una vez que se asumió que la posibilidad
de la conquista fácil de kiev y la
decapitación del gobierno ucraniano
simplemente no iba a ocurrir en una
situación así se concentrará en un
objetivo reducido como era completar la
ocupación incompleta desde el 2014 por
el incidente del derribo del avión de
malaysian airlines m 17
generando de esa manera un conflicto
latente un conflicto de baja intensidad
que duró hasta precisamente de febrero
de este año en esa situación la captura
lista y desde la completación de la
ocupación de donde donets y luhansk
podría darle a vladimir putin una
ventana de oportunidad para
ha conseguido sus objetivos en el norte
sin embargo en hardcore la situación es
distinta y es que el ejército ucraniano
ha tenido éxito en una serie de
contraataque y en algunos momentos
incluso ha llegado a la frontera
binacional previo al 24 de febrero por
lo tanto esas operaciones deben ser
consideradas más bien como
estabilización del frente también los
ucranianos han continuado con ataques en
la zona de gerzón llegando incluso a la
cercanía de los arrabales de dicha
ciudad por lo tanto es un escenario
bastante fluido todavía si bien es
cierto las operaciones ya no tienen la
intensidad que tuvieron en los primeros
peces precisamente por el agotamiento de
ambos bandos desde una perspectiva
logística
simplemente el material los
abastecimiento combustible municiones el
personal disponible y ya está al límite
prácticamente el fuego también
viridiana su opinión sobre esta
necesidad de conquistar estas dos
ciudades en la región del tomba lo que
significaría ya una caída completa del
donbass y que se puede decir de ese
retiro de tropas del norte abandonar a
las como un punto estratégico para
alcanzar en términos militares quien no
ha vuelto a ser tocada por parte de las
tropas rusas en los últimos días y la
ciudad incluso comienza a retomar cierto
aire de normalidad incluso están
comenzando a reconstruir algunos de los
daños que dejaron los primeros ataques
al inicio de la invasión
correcto si coincido con fernando que
muchas de las tácticas han sido bastante
fluidas en esta región siguiendo es
importante para rusia de alguna manera
nos resulta clave para el control de
ucrania de ninguna manera el retiro de
quien de alguna manera pareciera más
bien
una retirada quizás para reformular o
reestructurar quizás incluso buscar una
posición otra vez de negociación que
como bien que mencionabas es algo que
nunca ha dejado descartado vladimir
putin correcto la intención de retomar
negociaciones quizás la intención de
hacer una retirada es con la intención
de retomar fuerzas controlar esta región
y posteriormente volver a poner sobre la
mesa la oportunidad de una negociación
con en este caso pues el occidente
correcto pareciera que aún faltan pues
dos de las cuatro ciudades para
controlar el donde espero que es muy
pronto para anticiparnos es necesario el
es seguir a la expectativa un poco de
hacia dónde van los movimientos ahora
sobre todo también con la gran aporte
militar que ha hecho eeuu hacia el
frente de ucrania y como esto también ha
provocado que de alguna manera la
balanza se vaya inclinando conforme los
meses están pasando prácticamente un río
es lo que está impidiendo el paso de las
tropas de rusia en es la bianca para que
la conquisten y se enfrenten
directamente con las tropas
ucranianas viridiana continuó con usted
una caída de la región del donbass una
conquista completa digámoslo así por
parte de los rusos que significaría
entonces para ucrania porque recordemos
que esa zona ese cinturón del este de
ucrania junto con jarquín en el noreste
hacen parte de la zona más desarrollada
en términos económicos de ucrania la
gran zona industrializada del país el
oeste de ucrania es mucho más agrícola
esta zona de ucrania es donde se
encuentran las fábricas era el poder
económico del país significaría un paso
un punto de quiebre para ucrania en el
conflicto como lo vio usted
es muy interesante este punto que
mencionas porque efectivamente tenemos
dos posturas claves en este momento por
un lado tenemos esta exposición de la
crisis alimentaria tan importante que
viene a través de lo que tú mencionas
que es esta zona caracterizada por el
trigo etcétera ya sabemos bien que
fueron hace unos par de días bombardeada
por el ejército ruso y donde ya hubo
también declaraciones con relación a
esta crisis alimentaria que está
retornando el propio o la propia rusia
incluso declaraciones por parte a lo que
vamos deber de administrar las
interiores de kiev quien menciona que
bueno pues pareciera que rusia está
buscando los juegos del hambre' knox
sigue buscando consumir recursos acabar
con los recursos de alguna manera de
ucrania o bien el control
definitivamente el control de esta zona
representaría el control hasta cierto
punto de la industrialización de ucrania
sin embargo de nueva cuenta creo que es
muy pronto todavía para emitir una
resolución o una declaración ya que los
pasos de guti como bien nacional
fernando de alguna manera aparecieran
hasta cierto punto un tanto desesperado
no por ello menos cautos debemos de ser
pero si hasta cierto punto un tanto
desesperados y fernando cuál es su
opinión una conquista completa del
donbass estas son industrializada a
punto de quiebre en el conflicto
a veces si no pero el eje m por el cual
eres persona es básicamente por la
presencia de habitantes pro rusos que
buscan retornar al seno de la madre
rusia de hecho las repúblicas populares
de luhansk y donets se establecen
básicamente sobre la base de población
rusoparlante ahora el valor industrial
se centra esencialmente en jarkko todo
en excluyen setera son ciudades en los
cuales se puede comparar con el fenómeno
del raspeig del arco del óxido en el
norte de estados unidos es decir
estructuras industriales que digamos se
recaen a la unión soviética y que en
general no han tenido mayor fortuna en
reconvertirse a las nuevas estructuras
económicas y productivas occidentales es
que le permitirían insertarse por
ejemplo en los mercados de la unión
europea américa del norte hacia este
pero no cabe duda que la principal
potencia económica ucraniana hoy día son
las exportaciones de trigo y cereales y
de alguna manera el bloqueo marítimo
ruso apunta precisamente a ese tema
tiendo a creer que
la relevancia rusa es más bien de orden
político y geopolítico cultural antes de
industrial sobre todo porque no teniendo
ya los volúmenes de tropas y potencia de
fuego directo digamos infantería
mecanizada blindados como los que tenía
hace cuatro meses atrás cinco meses
atrás han tenido que recurrir lo
comparte de artillería y eso hace que
las ciudades estén prácticamente
demolida por lo tanto más que quedarse
con núcleos industriales se va a quedar
con enormes torres de escombros en los
cuales sólo pueden reclamar habérselo
quitado su cráneo claro son un reclamo
territorial avanzó con otro tema de la
agenda también otro hecho destacado de
la semanaeste lo mencionaba fernando la
firma de ese protocolo formal para la
incorporación de suecia y finlandia en
la otan en el marco de esa reunión que
hubo en madrid un proceso muy
controvertido conocemos la posición que
tuvo turquía para
toda esta negociación y lo que implicó
para estocolmo y para helsinki negociar
con ankara pero a los ojos de rusia tal
parece que el presidente putin
no le molesta la posibilidad de que
estos países se incorporen a la alianza
atlántica lo vio con buenos ojos no hizo
ningún tipo de comentario y bueno y
tampoco hizo ninguna de sus habituales
amenazas como se puede entender desde
rusia la incorporación de este de estos
dos países sobre todo en finlandia que
es un país que tiene fronteras 1.300
kilómetros de frontera con rusia a ver
esto es la pesadilla final rusa esta es
la derrota estratégica de rusia rusia
supuestamente invade ucrania
precisamente con el objetivo de mantener
de construir un buffer son de construir
una zona de seguridad frente a la otan y
ahora consigue finlandia congeladas de
los tratados de paz
en el contexto de la segunda guerra
mundial firmado el año 44 y suecia que
ha sido neutral desde 1815 desde el
congreso de viena se encuentran se
alinean firmemente con europa y hoy día
se constituye para todos los efectos
prácticos una verdadera barrera de
estados de la otan desde el océano
ártico hasta los dardanelos e incluso
hasta el cáucaso eso ciertamente es la
mayor derrota estratégica se ha tenido
desde la disolución de la unión
soviética y esto anula todas las
operaciones anteriores en la toma de
crimea del 2014 de la invasión de
georgia en 2007 etcétera y en esa
situación eso ya basta para considerarlo
una derrota rural ahora podrá conseguir
eventualmente victorias de carácter más
táctico más localizado como bien
mencionaba viridiana toda guerra termina
en una negociación de paz todo es
siempre la el objetivo de una guerra
como lo planteaba con klaus es
precisamente una mejor paz es la que
existía al principio pero el mero hecho
de la incorporación de finlandia y
suecia lo tanto es un cambio tectónico
en la geopolítica europea que es para
todos los efectos prácticos una enorme
derrota para rusia fernando pero
entonces en ese contexto de lo que usted
explica esta incorporación de suecia y
finlandia muy puntual por favor que
tanto tiene de estratégico por parte de
la otan y que tanto es verdaderamente
que suecia y finlandia se sienten
amenazados por las acciones que ha
tomado rusia en los últimos meses nunca
bueno es directo tanto a la primera
ministra finesa como la primera ministra
sueca han sido explícitas en términos de
definir y rusia no era el país que
creían que era es decir del miedo
explícito está ahí ahora justo reconocer
eso ese tenía un tratado secreto por lo
que eeuu y lo tanto durante la guerra
fría cosa de que la alianza atlántica
concurrir en su ayuda frente a una
amenaza educación y finlandia si bien es
cierto no tiene ese acuerdo o sea una
fuerza militar considerable su ejército
que consiguió detener a los rusos en el
año 40 y en el año 44 que hoy día es una
fuerza militar realmente digna de
respeto por lo tanto claramente si es
que están decidiendo entrar a lo tanto
es porque se sienten directamente
amenazados
esto es una postulación de los países
escandinavos no una imposición del otan
importante aclarar ese punto vil y danna
continuó con ustedes y en la ciudad de
querétaro teniendo como punto de partida
ese discurso digamos ambiguo que tiene
muchas veces el presidente putin que
lanza amenazas como la que mencionábamos
que lanzó hacia occidente pero luego ve
esta incorporación de suez y finlandia
como un punto simplemente que hace parte
de la política exterior de estos dos
países y no le da la importancia que se
pensó que le iba a dar podríamos esperar
en algún tipo de reacción también
inesperada por parte de rusia contra
estos dos países o contra la misma
ucrania simplemente en retaliación por
esta incorporación
y esto que mencionas otra vez creo que
es importante hacer hincapié éxitos
enfocamos en esta firma de protocolo
desde el área de la que política como
bien fernando mencionó efectivamente
pareciera que es ya la pérdida o
podríamos ya y con esto decimos cantar
victoria para el régimen o la región del
occidente
sin embargo cuando nos vamos un poco más
a profundidad lo analizamos desde la
parte democrática yo creo que es la
parte que la discutimos está
considerando recordemos que social está
en rne de este protocolo está firmando
lo sin embargo hubo aquí una serie de
destrezas bastante complejas al interior
de suecia de las cuales hubo una
modificación en su propia legislación y
se está notando se está haciendo ver en
la crisis democrática el interior de
europa donde pareciera que los militares
mucho más intencional que
prioridad que tenemos sobre las
democracias en el mundo no solamente por
hablar de europa señor mi general creo
que esto es algo que le está costando un
poco vladimir putin es decir
estratégicamente pareciera que ya cantó
victoria sin embargo habría que ver
realmente la intencionalidad con la que
se firmaron estos protocolos y ver
realmente si el momento de presentar
acción no ser necesaria la acción de
alguien como suecia evidentemente
militarmente es poderoso y realmente se
involucraría como se asume o se espera
que así sea
cuando hablamos otra vez al interior de
suecia no sé qué tan buenos ojos
realmente se está viendo esta
participación y estas modificaciones que
se tuvieron que hacer y dejando un lado
el tema de tu pierna
si hay hubo mucho debate en la sociedad
sueca sobre el abandono de esta posición
de neutralidad para incorporarse a la
otan muchos de los ciudadanos lo vieron
con buenos ojos en términos de defensa
ante una amenaza externa pero a la hora
de tener que participar o involucrar el
país en un conflicto es donde se abre
otro debate en esta sociedad paso a otro
punto de la lista de hechos a lo largo
de la semana
viridiana y es esa
conferencia que tuvo lugar en suiza
precisamente para reunir fondos ayudas y
unir esfuerzos a nivel internacional
para la reconstrucción de ucrania los
países involucrados y los organismos que
intervinieron allí dijeron que
reconstruirán ucrania a pesar de que el
conflicto no ha finalizado
no hay una mesa de diálogo abierta que
decir de esta de esta mesa de
negociación y qué decir de esta
reconstrucción que se busca hacer de
ucrania cuando el mundo entero está ante
una crisis económica ante una inminente
recesión ante una inminente hambruna y
con la inflación disparada en
prácticamente todas las economías de
dónde va a salir plata para reconstruir
a ucrania
justo frente las intenciones ellos son
buenas sin embargo la práctica es lo que
lo vuelve un poco
quizás cuestionable sería la palabra
sobre todo porque me parece muy curioso
había algunos autores que emocionan como
el plan marshall de ucrania y me parece
muy curioso porque pareciera que
queremos regresar un poco a cuestiones
de guerra fría e incluso hay autores que
vuelven a mencionar el tema de este
revival o reavivamiento de la guerra
fría
que me parece que quizás en este momento
y el contexto no tienen cabida realmente
estos términos y más bien nos de esports
el fan de temas que si me lo preguntas
pero que son realmente prioritarios no
tú lo acabas de mencionar estamos
próximos de enfrentar una crisis
económica no vista en los últimos 50 a
70 años y la situación inflacionaria no
solamente no europa sino en todo el
mundo américa latina también y eso nos
hace pensar no solamente si tan buenas
intenciones tienen porque todos los
tenemos pero que realmente ocurrirá si
es que esto finalmente se construyera
este año o si finalmente llegará a más
con esta guerra que hay entre bueno por
parte de rusia hacia ucrania
esto es realmente reformas o estas
propuestas quedarían al aire como otras
tantas intenciones que han dejado verse
en este conflicto con ucrania donde
finalmente el gran
hasta cierto punto abandonado podría ser
en este sistema internacional de trani
en este punto no soy fernando algo que
decir de esta ayuda internacional que se
va a destinar para la reconstrucción de
ucrania y pongo sobre la mesa de una vez
el tema de una posible negociación
vladimir putin ha dicho podemos negociar
pero si no tomáramos mucho porque este
conflicto se está extendiendo que esa
ventana de negociación se puede cerrando
otra amenaza se puede tomar por parte de
occidente
saber que comparto con lo que planteaba
viridiana en términos de que
efectivamente es improbable que uno
pueda pensar esto pueda resolverse sobre
la base simplemente poner dinero en la
cuenta del estado ucraniano sin embargo
un aspecto quizás menos estético menos
elegante pero probablemente bastante más
práctico y útil en términos de
reconstrucción se han otorgar contratos
a grandes compañías occidentales las
cuales puedan hacerse cargo sobre la
base de concesiones o
monopolios fiscales etcétera de la
reconstrucción de parte de la
infraestructura por ejemplo vial camión
camino puente infraestructura capacidad
manufacturas etcétera
en la propia ucrania es decir ver lo más
que como un vaciado de dinero en las
arcas ucranianas como oportunidades de
negocio tenemos ejemplo quizás no
demasiado estéticos durante la operación
iraqí freedom en en irak el 2003 donde
la reconstrucción se entregó a parte en
buena parte a grandes empresas
norteamericanas al everton incluso
vinculado con la clara campus con el
vicepresidente cheney por lo tanto nos
encontramos de alguna forma con un
sistema una situación que tiene dos que
tiene buscar ahora sobre las amenazas de
putin bueno la verdad es que a menos que
esté dispuesto a recurrir a armas de
destrucción masiva algo que se habló
explícitamente entre durante el tercer
mes de guerra
de gam armas nucleares primero armas
químicas después incluso a soldados
rusos se los capturó
llevando
kits de supervivencia química e
inyecciones de yodo etcétera antídotos
etcétera lo cual demuestra que en algún
momento se lo pensó la verdad es que a
uno le queda la duda que más podría
rusia hacer sobre ucrania se le ha
lanzado toda clase de misiles y armas y
nada comparte o pasivos de artillería
ataques aéreos
digamos y bueno una invasión con más de
250.000 hombres y con cerca de 15.000
vehículos plantados por lo tanto en
términos prácticos la verdad es que a
menos que se recurriera a esos
instrumentos uno no se le ocurre más
bien qué es lo que podría hacer vladimir
putin realmente no haya empleado no haya
usado todavía y en cuanto a la mesa de
diálogo viridiana es posible hay espacio
para esto las condiciones que pone en
cada una de las partes son muy rigurosas
y muy difíciles de cumplir en algunos
puntos por ejemplo sólo por citar una
rusia exige ucrania acepta la
independencia como base de las dos
repúblicas populares de donets y lugansk
como punto de partida para sentarse a
negociar algo que quiere ya dijo no hay
ningún tipo de discusión sobre el tema
mira creo que hay varios actores que
tenemos que analizar y para mí uno de
los más interesantes es la opinión
pública existe alrededor de este tipo de
negociaciones algo que no sé si han
estado observando pero incluso yo existe
un trending twitter con relación a esto
donde los alemanes dicen ya se
independice en estas regiones acepten la
independencia estas regiones y acabemos
con esta guerra no que no es nuestra
guerra que este es como mucha la postura
que existe el amigo alrededor de unión
europea
específicamente los puntos de
negociación creo que hablar en este
punto de llegar a un acuerdo es muy
pronto
hay muchos todavía temas y vertientes
que hay que revisar
creo que hay todavía muchos recursos que
pueden o cartas que pueden jugar todavía
tanto tienen como la otan que
evidentemente ya se acaban la primera
con estos protocolos pero también rusia
tiene cartas que todavía puede jugar si
bien pareciera que ya quedó cercado como
lo mencionaba fernando y creo que algo
que nos ha dejado claro durante estos
seis meses rusia es que no es un jugador
que podamos
de alguna manera desacreditar o dar como
garantizado que sabemos o conocemos los
movimientos que puedan realizar me gusta
pensar que si estamos en una situación a
la que podamos llegar próximamente a
unax
resolución de paz quizás sí pero lo
cierto es que no se resaltan no se
acercan a las partes discrepan en
muchísimos puntos necesarios para
sentarse a negociar me quieren ya pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa y
quiero hablar sobre la posición de rusia
a nivel internacional veíamos esta
semana el canciller ruso sérguei lávrov
abandonando esa cumbre de cancilleres
del g20 en la isla de bali en indonesia
porque aparentemente se dice en los
medios occidentales los otros países
visitantes allí integrantes de esta
cumbre no quisieron tomarse la foto de
grupo con él y muchos de los delegados
de los cancilleres y ministros de
relaciones exteriores trataron de
dejarlo un poco al lado y evitar tener
contacto con él frente a los medios de
comunicación esto sumado también a las
sanciones que ya han impuesto a estados
unidos la unión europea canadá ha
anunciado que impondrá más sanciones
también la unión europea ha dicho que
buscará abaratar el precio del petróleo
ruso para seguir afectando las arcas
están estas sanciones verdaderamente
teniendo su
su efecto está rusia poco a poco
quedándose aislada en estos escenarios
multilaterales
fernando cuál es su opinión
primero digamos quizás la puntualizar
que la alternativa más dura que existe
respecto al final de este conflicto es
precisamente que no termine que quede
reducido un conflicto de baja intensidad
un pack werner warning antiguo fan prevé
que simplemente se extienda como lo hace
la frontera entre las dos coreas o la
franja de gaza por un periodo abierto de
tiempo y en esa situación es que rusia
corre el severísimo riesgo de quedar aún
más aislada de lo que está hoy día es
muy difícil pensar en las sanciones la
totalidad la sanción aplicado es sea
levantada en forma automática incluso si
en el casi imposible caso de vladimir
putin estuviera dispuesto a ceder
tomba el donbass completo etcétera
más aún es muy difícil que rusia vuelva
a recuperar la confianza internacional
en términos de atraer inversión
extranjera
recordemos las decenas de compañías que
se retiraron incluso abandonaron
sus posiciones mcdonough se dedique a
que decidieron literalmente su compañía
ahora en esa en esa situación rusia yo
creo que ya estructuralmente y por un
plazo a lo menos media no va a quedar
segregado de los grandes mercados
internacionales salvo china que es un
cuchillo de dólar los para ellos porque
es un enemigo histórico y corren el
riesgo de ser devorados económicamente
por lo que en algún momento algún sal
llamó la amenaza amarilla que luego fue
recogido por guillermo segundo de
alemania etcétera la gran amenaza
oriental se y viridiana su conclusión
sobre este tema para el cierre del
programa
en contracción y para no extenderme
demasiado creo que mucho se resume en
faltas de liderazgo que hay en la
actividad mencionabas y justamente la
reunión del g20 y estos actores que han
recibido quizás no verse mezclados con
el ministro lavín sectario ruso y
justamente que la pregunta es entonces
dónde está el discurso de occidente
entonces incluimos no incluimos queremos
firmar la pasó no queremos firmar la paz
queremos diálogo no queremos diálogo y
creo que esto que no tiene que tenemos
que reflexionar en la narrativa que
están manejando occidente porque lo
cierto es que también ha dejado mucho
que desear creo que de ahí es que ha
tenido el time un perfecto vladimir
putin para llevar a cabo toda esta
estrategia que empezó desde finales del
año pasado y que podemos ver al día de
hoy
justamente un timing que nos deja claro
que al menos en la unión europea o
incluso eeuu la falta de liderazgo es lo
que ha permitido que al día de hoy rusia
siga siendo tan efectivo como lo ha sido
bueno pues son las palabras de viridiana
para la conclusión del programa
habilidad de fernando les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros haciendo este
análisis de los hechos más recientes en
torno a la guerra en ucrania en torno a
esas amenazas que lanzó el presidente
vladimir putin a occidente sobre el
desarrollo de este conflicto en el este
de europa ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales ya las
conocen y también los invito para que
sigan oyendo todo el contenido de el
debate de france 24 a través de las
diferentes plataformas de podcast donde
ya está disponible los diferentes
programas que hemos tenido a lo largo de
la semana pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]